-It's good to see you buddy.
-Good to see you.
-i haven't seen you
since "Top Gun: Maverick"
was the number-one --
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
-The number-one movie that --
I think it's --
I think it's the fifth highest
grossing film
in American history.
-Yeah.
-Congratulations, buddy.
-Yeah, still climbing.
-You did it.
-Every day.
-Yeah, every -- that is correct.
-Yeah.
-Uh, it's bigger than
we even thought
it was gonna be.
-Oh, for sure.
-It was fantastic.
-I know, people just --
people really love --
Well, they love Tom Cruise,
which -- as they should.
He's dedicated...
-Of course.
-...so much of his life
to entertaining audiences.
But people just love "Top Gun."
-Yeah.
-They cannot get enough of it.
-I love the story, though.
I love you.
You did it so -- you were --
it was just --
Everything was great.
-Thank you.
-Jennifer Connelley.
-I know, right?
She's so good.
-The greatest in everything.
But we had --
-Val, a nice --
a really touching performance
from Val.
-I lost it.
I even knew that was
gonna happen, and I --
I watched it, and I was like --
I still lost it.
-How did you know
it was gonna happen?
-I have an inside scoop.
-A little inside --
-Yeah, yeah.
-Well, you're in the biz, Jimmy.
-Well, you know, I had Jon --
Jon Hamm was on the show
a couple times.
And he told me that, you know,
you met the royals...
-Yes.
-...because you screened it
in London.
-Yeah, yeah.
-And it was like -- and it --
and he was telling me, he goes,
"Yeah, it was really
interesting and fun."
And he said that the cast
was all told,
"Hey, be very polite.
Don't say too much."
-Oh, they give -- they give you,
like, a full kind of rules,
like do's and don'ts.
And there's, you know, a lot of
etiquette, which deservingly so.
So, yeah, I was actually --
I kind of had a sheet to prep
to make sure
I didn't mess it up.
-But then he said --
-Yeah.
-Well, I have just a photo.
And I just want you
to explain the photo,
'cause here's you talking.
-Yeah.
-There's Jennifer Connelley.
-Right.
-Little concerned.
-Yeah. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Laughing.
-Sure.
-Right?
Kate Middleton laughing.
And then --
-Yeah.
-He's going, "Mm-hmm."
-"Mm-hmm."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-And so what is happening?
Can you tell us the story of
what's going on with this?
-I think right off the bat,
I messed up.
You're not supposed to, like,
extend your hand
right off the bat unless --
unless they do.
But I felt the vibe,
so I was like, "I'm --"
[ Laughter ]
I was like, "I'm going in.
I'm going in."
-"Felt the vibe."
-And to their credit,
they were very disarming,
and this and that.
But, yeah, if you --
I think right there,
I'm honestly lost
in Prince William's -- in his --
in his eyes.
[ Laughter ]
-Tell me about this, though.
-His eyes?
-No. But yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, blue
as the bluest ocean, Jimmy.
What do you want?
-You get right in there,
and you go, "Hi,"
and you just start going gaga?
-Kind of.
Like, um, and Kate is very --
You know, she's...
-Yeah.
-...beautiful and very,
you know, cordial and...
-Stunning, yeah.
-...holds herself so well.
-Regal.
-Yeah, regal.
And with William, I don't know.
I just --
[ Laughter ]
I blacked out.
-I just think -- this photo,
I just think --
And then Jennifer Connelley
looks at you, she goes,
"That was weird
what you just did to him."
[ Laughter ]
-'Cause she knew, 'cause I was
standing next to Jen.
So I was kind of --
I don't know.
I was kind of riffing on what --
what this interaction
was gonna be like.
So I think she was already
on alert about --
if she thought I was gonna
go a bit rogue
about the whole thing.
But I think he's
a lifelong fan now.
-Yeah, now --
now he has to be, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
He felt the vibe was the best.
You know --
-Just picking up
what he was putting down.
-I want to give a shout-out
to your grandma, by the way,
if she's watching.
-Oh, for sure.
-Hi, grandma.
-Yeah.
-You're so proud of your
grandson here.
She's on Twitter, and she said,
"They're looking for an actor
to replace Daniel Craig
for a 007.
I think my grandson,
Miles Teller,
has proven that he has
everything they're looking for.
Talent, looks, strength,
worldwide appeal,
and, oh, so cool."
[ Laughter ]
"He can be that guy!!
Wouldn't he be great?"
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Yeah.
-You had no idea
she was going to do this?
-No.
And I'm not -- look.
I set her up
her Twitter many years ago.
-Yeah.
-I'm not gonna tell her
what to do with it.
-No.
-Do what you want, grandma,
you know?
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Yeah.
-If you want to --
if you want to --
-But I am actually here
to make an announcement.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-Still not 007.
-All right, well, hey.
You know -- it's so --
-Nobody's -- nobody's called.
-No one's called yet.
-Yeah, yeah.
-We got to get Barbara Broccoli
on the phone here
and make this official.
I mean, I could see you as 007.
-Yeah, why not?
-I mean --
-Yeah, you know?
What do you guys think?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Why not?
-Mix it up.
Why not do it?
-But I am available.
[ Laughter ]
-This is one of my favorite
times of the year,
because this is
"Saturday Night Live"
season premiere time...
-Oh, my God.
-...and I'm so --
As a comedian, even before
I was on "Saturday Night Live,"
I get excited in September.
I go, "Oh, this is
'Saturday Night Live.'"
There's some new cast members.
-I know.
-And it's just fun.
We want it, we need it.
-Definitely new cast members
this year, yeah.
-Yeah. Oh, yeah.
This is fantastic.
-I know, I know.
-Are you nervous?
Are you excited?
-I'm very --
Yeah, I mean,
it's all those things.
Like I --
in my family, growing up,
"SNL" was, you know,
an institution.
It still is.
-Yeah.
-You know, the years that you
were there and before that --
you know, Cheri Oteri and
Will Farrell and Chris Kattan
and Ana Gasteyer
and Molly Shannon,
like, those were --
-Love it.
-It was a real thing.
And, you know, my sisters and I
would do the skits,
and our close family friends,
it was our collective dream
to one day, you know,
either be a cast member on "SNL"
or to host,
so, it's very --
-Did you get any advice
from any other --
-That's why I'm here.
Give me some advice.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Like, what do you --
-Uh, yeah.
Try everything.
-Yeah.
-Try and believe in the writers.
-Sounds like college.
-Believe -- yeah, exactly.
[ Laughter ]
Believe in the writers.
Believe in the producers.
They're all
the best of the best.
And they'll all just --
and you do it.
Whatever works is gonna work.
Just try everything
and just go all out.
It's just -- honestly.
And they all love you already.
I already heard word back
from down the hall.
-Okay, good.
-Yeah, and they said,
"Yeah, he's a good guy."
-Okay, good.
-"We love Miles Teller."
-Good, good.
-Yeah.
-Guys, I'm freaking out.
-No, yeah.
It's good.
-No, I'm excited.
-You should.
You should freak out
the whole time.
-You know, you're --
I get -- I just --
I'm excited to see
how it all works.
-It's live TV, man.
-You know what I mean?
-It's fun. No one does live TV
anymore, so it's great.
-Yeah.
-So congratulations.
Break a leg.
You're gonna be great.
-Thank you.
-And you got
Kendrick Lamar, too.
-Oh, my God.
-So everyone's watching
this Saturday.
It's gonna be fun.
I want to talk to you
about something.
And this is very interesting
to me.
You're an investor
in this stuff,
in this beverage called
"Long Drink."
-Right.
-I like this stuff,
and I didn't know even that you
were an investor in this stuff.
-It's fantastic, yeah.
So this -- I got involved, uh,
I was just -- I made my way
into a liquor store
couple years ago in New York.
I was doing
some grocery shopping,
some odds and ends and things.
-Yeah.
-And, no,
but I tried this stuff,
and, you know, met the guys.
And it's basically like the
national beverage of Finland.
They hosted the Olympics
in 1952.
They had to figure out a way
to kind of, you know,
get mass amounts of alcohol
out to people quickly.
They came up with this stuff.
Has anybody here tried it?
Have you guys had it?
-Yeah.
-A couple people --
a couple very cool people
have tried it.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh.
-A couple not-so-cool people
need to try it.
No, but it's really --
I mean, it tastes --
-I loved it.
-It's gin, so it's not --
you know, it's not a seltzer.
It tastes like a Fresca.
It's really refreshing.
Sugar free.
The original.
This is strong.
This is like 8.5 --
[ Laughter ]
-Really?
-Like 8.5%.
-Yeah.
-And then the cranberry
is really nice, but, um --
-I went with the original,
'cause my wife is Finnish.
So we --
when I go, "Honey, this is
the reason for me to drink this
is because of you."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, and we have
to finish all of it.
-Ah! I like that.
[ Laughter ]
The Finnish Long Drink --
is that what they ended up
calling -- that was
the name of the beverage?
-So, if you go to Finland,
they have --
I mean, there's a bunch
of different brands kind of
doing their version
of the Long Drink.
It's like their national
kind of beverage.
So, yeah, ours is, you know --
If you go to longdrink.com,
you can find out
where they're selling it
around you, and then you can --
you can try it out.
-It's really --
Should we try one?
Let's go.
-Yeah, I would love to.
-Which one?
-Oh, I was, like, curious
when we were gonna
get to that part.
-I'm gonna go -- I'm gonna go --
I'll go for the strong.
-There you go.
-I'll go for the strong.
-I'll go original.
♪♪
Little drinking music?
-Yeah.
Always with the...
-Cheers to you,
cheers to "Top Gun,"
cheers to "Saturday Night Live."
-Thank you. Appreciate it.
-Miles Teller.
Congratulations, buddy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Break a leg.
Miles Teller is hosting
"Saturday Night Live"
this weekend with musical guest
Kendrick Lamar.
We're playing "Drinko"
with Miles after the break.
Stick around.